le budget 2015-2016 présenté par joe a
révélé c'est le budget du retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire mais à quel prix
le gouvernement a dû gratter dans tous
les tiroirs pour arriver à l'équilibré
budgétaire pour deux raisons
essentiellement il manque 6 milliards de
dollars en revenus depuis la mise à jour
économique de novembre dernier dans les
revenus budgétaires du gouvernement
li manque à peu près 5 6 milliards
également en raison des mesures qui ont
été annoncées notamment le
fractionnement du revenu donc pour aller
chercher l'argent manquant le
gouvernement d'abord peut dire merci aux
marchés obligataires les taux d'intérêt
ont chuté on recherchait 3 milliards en
intérêts gagnés en quelque sorte on pige
dans la réserve pour éventualités ce qui
est extrêmement rare au gouvernement au
lieu d'avoir une réserve de 3 milliards
on a une réserve d'un milliard donc on
va chercher 2 milliards on coupe dans
les prévisions généralement le
gouvernement est très prudent sur ses
prévisions de croissance du pib plus
prudent que le secteur privé soit si on
coupe dans la marge de manoeuvre on va
chercher 2 milliard à 1 milliards qui
provient de la vente des actions de gm
congé maladie congés pour invalidité
dans le secteur public on pense aller
chercher près d'un milliard de dollars
et la caisse de l'assurance emploi est
en surplus de près de 2 milliards donc
tout ça permet au gouvernement
finalement d'afficher un surplus
d'impôts 1 milliard 400 millions pour
2015 2016 trois choses à retenir quand
même de ce budget beaucoup de mesures
pour les aînés les 55 ans et plus vous
savez le celi le compte d'épargné libre
d'impôt va passer à une cotisation
maximale annuelle de 10 mille dollars
70% des gens qui ont un celi ont 55 ans
et plus et puis le retrait obligatoire
annuelle pour le faire le fonds
enregistré de revenu de retraite sera
abaissé le taux de retrait
habituellement que vous devez retirer
qui est assez élevé d'année en année eh
ben ce taux là va baisser vous allez
avoir un peu plus de capacités
financières de ce côté là les
entreprises plusieurs mesures pour les
entreprises donc toutes les petites
entreprises verront leur taux
d'imposition baissé de 11 à 9% d'ici
2019 et beaucoup d'argent pour la
défense et la sécurité près de 12
milliards de dollars de plus sur 10 ans
dans le secteur de la défense